de la réforme a commencé par sa mesure
le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans les sages ne se
prononcent pas sur le front de la
réforme mais sa conformité à la
Constitution alors attention là ce que
vous voyez ça n'est pas une photo c'est
une vidéo
si
on attend si on attend 20 minutes il y
en a il y en a un qui va bouger une
photo qui illustre bien la crise liée à
la réforme des retraites
la présence de plusieurs dizaines de
gendarmes devant le Conseil
constitutionnel crée la polémique et
indigne de nombreux politiques de
l'opposition
ce dispositif a été mobilisé la veille
de la décision des sages sur le projet
de loi du gouvernement des internautes y
voit un parallèle avec le Seigneur des
anneaux ou encore Star Wars le conseil
la constitutionnel qui a censuré
certains articles notamment
l'index senior et le contrat de travail
senior des mesures sociales jugées hors
sujet dans un texte budgétaire au grand
regret de la gauche
en supprimant tous les cavaliers sociaux
de la loi il n'en applique que la partie
comptable la partie la plus dure
c'est-à-dire les deux ans de plus quelle
suite pour la mobilisation cette nuit le
président de la République a promulgué
la loi sur les retraites malgré la
contestation il faut y voir une
provocation selon les syndicats qui
l'assurent le mouvement va continuer
certaines c'est le président de la
République lui souhaite passer
rapidement cette cette étape je vous
assure qu'il se trompe la colère est
très profonde en France je crois que
Macron va avoir ce qu'il veut c'est à
dire une insurrection c'est pas possible
autrement je crois que la rue va parler
elle va parler très fort de nouvelles
manifestations devraient avoir lieu dans
la journée avant une grande journée de
mobilisation prévue le 1er mai
inflation sur le rayon des couches qui
est vraiment un produit qui a fortement
augmenté parce que c'est
ça a augmenté de entre 30 et 50%
alors voilà ce qui se passe en fait dans
un monde rempli de haine nous devons
encore
oser espérer dans un monde rempli de
colère nous devons encore consoler dans
un monde rempli de désespoir nous devons
encore oser rêver et dans un monde
rempli de méfiance nous devons encore
oser croire et c'est de Michael Jackson
[Applaudissements]
dont on parle allons les voir sur le
terrain loin
cette émission si je peux quand même
juste en placer une il y a plus autant
de gens brillants pour faire de la
politique pourquoi parce que parce que
on gagne plus d'argent en faisant des
affaires on a moins de juge qui vous
tombe sur le râble je veux dire on est
c'est un métier épouvantable c'est un
métier vraiment dangereux et
épouvantable qui détruit la vie
familiale qui détruit tout donc les gens
les plus brillants
il y en a dans la politique mais moins
qu'avant et ils sont ailleurs bon ça
c'est la présence des émissions de télé
c'est ce que vous voulez dire
en quatre en quatre on a François Bayrou
que des arts
parce que j'ai pris du plus au moins
mais
je vais vous le dire j'adorais cette
phrase Dominique Sarkozy je t'ai moins
fan du monsieur mais je trouve que c'est
un personnage de théâtre en fait
Monsieur Sarkozy c'est un vrai
personnage de théâtre le rappeur
américain Jay-Z a fait son retour sur
scène c'était hier soir à Paris invité
de la Fondation Vuitton le concert
surprise avait été annoncé deux jours
plus tôt les places étaient comptées
beaucoup de beau monde dans le public
regardez Rihanna ici dans les tribunes
on va voir Rihanna juste au-dessus deux
ministres deux ministres du gouvernement
en train de se déhancher Rima Abdul
malaquée Hervé Berville en charge de la
culture et de la mer ce qui n'a pas
manqué de faire réagir en cette période
sociale agitée
[Musique]
il me semble que
serait moins pénible au soleil c'est une
première en France un maire élu en tant
qu'homme et qui change de sexe au cours
de son mandat depuis ce matin à
Estevelles dans le Pas-de-Calais Alain
Zabo est devenu Estelle les 2000
habitants de la commune seront désormais
administrés par Madame le Maire heureuse
de l'accueil que qui lui a été réservé
et fier d'avoir franchi le pas il faut
quand même un petit peu de courage sans
prétention aucune ou soit en fausse
modestie
[Applaudissements]
menée sur 68000 personnes dans 180 pays
ce que les femmes désirent chez les
hommes c'est dans l'ordre un beau
sourire puis des beaux yeux puis des
bras musclés en fait le pénis n'arrive
qu'en 6e position il est chargé
c'est nouveau pour les hommes d'être
traité d'un dixième de comme on traitait
comment
ont été traités les femmes depuis des
siècles ou des décennies tu as voulu
faire une phrase
[Applaudissements]
triple question toujours demeurer sans
réponse jusqu'à ce jour qui sommes-nous
d'où venons-nous où allons-nous je
réponds en ce qui me concerne
personnellement je suis moi je viens de
chez moi et il retourne